it looks like it's covered in warts it's
like is it burning this is gonna be
weird I'm Alexis and I'm the senior food
specialist here at Taste State today my
co-workers challenged me to make a
three-course meal using only one
appliance do I get to choose what
appliance oh you can leave it I don't
drink coffee and I think I've made
coffee three times in my life I I don't
I like don't really know how this works
any good chef should be able to cook
with with anything so I'm up for the
challenge can I do some research okay so
apparently cooking with a coffee maker
is a thing so this part is gonna act as
like we can boil stuff in here and then
you can use the griddle griddle but I
could use this to try to get some color
this is gonna be weird I'm gonna start
with the truffles first since I need to
chill for a while so I'm gonna chop the
chocolate pretty finely so that way when
I add the hot heavy cream it's gonna mix
really easily oh I should be heating my
heavy cream right now we fit okay so
it's seven ounces of chocolate so I need
three and a half ounces of heavy cream
it seems like very little I guess we
just heat it up and see how hot it gets
[Music]
it kind of smells like it's burning
fine the cream doesn't need to be
scalding hot and you want it like more
than warm to the touch if you stuck your
finger in it you'd be like ha how long
does it take to make coffee in the
morning like 10 minutes more will it
work
it might be ready I hope this is hot
enough if you were in a hotel room and
really wanted chocolate truffles you
could totally do this I don't know why
what but Who am I to judge I'm going to
chill this and wash this out so I'm
gonna get the water going for my shrimp
I fear that it's gonna take a while
alright alright alright do I just pour
it in here like pour it in the big part
so that's why you add the water first
before turning it on this is a real
learning experience here this is a great
idea I'm going to start prepping
everything for mission ok the sounds
that it's making right now this is like
my childhood I this feels very familiar
I feel like this is doing what it's
supposed to it feels hot so I think I
can actually go ahead and add the shrimp
so we just want to make sure that the
shrimp is cooked through and pink.you
it's actually turning pink you can see
it turning pink this is amazing coffee
cooking my confidence level right now I
mean I don't want to get cocky but I
feel pretty optimistic they're actually
like perfectly good I actually have to
toast the coconut on the griddle before
I move on you know I feel good about
boiling things poaching things but I
don't know if the griddle is gonna work
internet said if I put tinfoil on it
it'll act as like a a pan this feels
I feel skeptical so I guess I'll just
let that get a little toasty if it does
you know I wanted to do something that I
would actually make at home I feel like
I would serve this at a dinner party or
just make it for myself that's another
reason I feel so excited about this is
I'm actually
Kame food I feel passionate about Oh oh
my god it's actually working it's
working it's working
look some what you can see some of the
brown bits the coconut got a little
brown and you taste some of the toasted
flavor I'm just gonna make sure this is
good I don't know if I'm allowed to say
like give myself a pat on the back but
this is really good
next I'm going to poach the salmon so
I'm just gonna heat it up like I did
before and it needs to be enough oil to
submerge the salmon and I'm just gonna
trim the salmon down so that it'll
actually fit in the cuff but I'm gonna
infuse the oil with some peppercorns
lemon rinds dill and that all heat up
together and infuse so I had this idea
to make these asparagus ribbons and I
was initially thinking about blanching
them but I think actually I could steam
them in the steamer basket because the
asparagus is so thin steam in it is
gonna work better than blanching that
stay tuned I'm getting the oil to about
180 before I poach its gonna add the
salmon and this is the weirdest thing
I've ever done so I'm gonna keep an eye
on this but it could be done anywhere
from like 7 to 15 minutes so while the
salmon is poaching I'm just gonna roll
the ganache into balls and let them
chill again before I roll them into the
cocoa powder I'm gonna go wash up okay
oh this looks really gross the fat is
clearly leaving the salmon but it looks
like oh my god it looks like it's
covered in warts there's like little
balls
oh okay oh okay but like a beautiful
notice look at that [ __ ] I'm gonna do a
few more minutes and then wipe off the
fat no one will ever know hmm
well the salmon finishes poaching I'm
gonna roll the truffles in the cocoa
powder I haven't tried these yet but
it's chocolate wait can't go to wrong
the salmon I don't know I'm gonna go
chill tease again and then my salmon
should be ready oh the day looks like a
sea creature oh we're good
perfect I'm gonna boil off this first
let me just flake this okay I mean it
looks beautiful it was great new salt
but it's really nice you can do olive
oil poached salmon in a coffee maker who
knew this needs a thorough wash after
what just happened on to part two so for
this I'm gonna like simmer some beans in
chicken stock and time just to try to
add some more flavor
I just putting beans in a coffee pot
feels wrong we're gonna salt and pepper
and let that do its thing if I put these
berries in the top and then add some
more chicken stock by the time the
chicken stock goes through it might be
done I don't I don't know
[Music]
oh my god it's like all right it's
already it's done that was so fast oh it
still has some texture to it it's not
mushy this is perfect I don't want to
speak too soon but it's going this is
going surprisingly well surprise the new
world the beans aren't really at a boil
but they're starting to kind of split
it's pretty good ah you know the coconut
got toasted have really nice color so
hopefully these tomatoes can black in
and kind of get some they can get some
color on them I don't think that's
totally gonna happen but hopefully they
can get some char oh okay there's some
sound oh there's a little bit of a
little bit of darken this is gonna be
really rustic my confidence is waning
I wish the beans were cooks more so like
post as if it was over real heat but
there's nothing else to use this is as
good as it's gonna get this meal could
have been done hours ago this is not
efficient in any way I'm almost done so
I'm gonna Tek some friends see if they
want to come up and try it and see if
they know that this was all done with a
coffee maker we do a lot of crazy stuff
at tasty so I feel like they're gonna
have some inclination that something's
up but I don't think they would guess a
coffee maker Wine and Dine you did this
to me I did it was a real struggle but I
have prepared a three-course meal
nonetheless of course one is a shrimp
salad I left you with a coffee maker
[Music]
I think it's actually really nice it's
like ceviche
yeah it's like something changes you
like the cook of the shrimp yeah we're
going onto course to we've got some
white beans with olive oil poached
salmon with steamed asparagus ribbons
and blistered tomatoes okay when you
left me this morning what did you think
was gonna happen
pour hot water but this is like a
healthy nutritious meal thought you'd
paid good money for one more thing that
course and then for dessert and how very
impressive thank you
I was challenged today to make all these
three courses with a twist I made all
three courses using only a coffee maker
I could have eaten coffee
clearly you know share this with the
team
coffee maker clean up and make a queen
going into today I was nervous this is
crazy this takes so long but if I was
ever in a pinch if there's the
apocalypse I can make dinner in a coffee
maker I'll be fine
[Music]
if this works this is the coolest please
work hi I'm Alexis and I'm the senior
food specialist here at tasty last time
my co-workers challenged me to make a
three-course meal using only a coffee
maker I'm expecting the worst but let's
see what they have in store this time
[Music]
okay the coffee maker was one thing but
I don't I what am I gonna do any good
chef should be able to cook with with
anything so luckily I have ironed many
clothes before but let's have a look the
first instruction is use iron only for
its intended use so don't try this at
home let's see what the Internet has to
say I just like who are these people
that test us out okay so this is clearly
a thing so I'm gonna see if I can
elevate clothing iron cooking just a
little bit so the first course I'm gonna
try to make a flatbread
with like a caramelized shallot dip so
because my dough for the flatbread needs
to sit I'm going to get started with
that and I do a really easy to
ingredient flatbread it's basically just
Greek yogurt and self-rising flour
self-rising flour has baking powder in
it so you don't need to add anything
else do I like ironing i mean i like
ironing more than vacuuming oh no you're
gonna try to make me do something with
the vacuum
this is going to rest for the second
course I'm going to make couscous and
lamb chops I'm going to marinate my lamb
chops so those gonna get really
flavorful and hopefully it'll mask the
fact that they are being cooked on iron
this is gonna be really simple it's just
garlic rosemary oil salt pepper it's
pretty classic so I got these tiny
little lamb chops and I thought like if
steak can be done so could a lamb chop
and you want them to be on the
medium-rare side so this actually could
work also if you look at the chopped
compared to the herd it's pretty perfect
so I'm just gonna blow up these so that
the marinade sticks it better to it so
these are ready I'm going to wash my
hands cover them and refrigerate them
thank you for the refrigerator for
dessert I'm going to try to make a crepe
cake but I'm not using a recipe it's
just like feed an egg
add a little flour or add a little milk
and just do it until you get a smooth
consistency so my mom's Dutch because I
grew up with crepes or Dutch Monica she
never followed a recipe so yeah this is
like my Sunday mornings as a kid so I'm
gonna do a few more rounds but that
should be good I'm gonna put it on the
linen setting which is the hottest and
see what happens this feels weird
[Music]
what do I do I don't know I've never
done this before
well I don't know what's gonna work it's
cooking in a way okay
Oh God this is not gonna work but
[Music]
Jesse this pretty perfect it would be
really helpful to have pots and pans I
just want to set up little butter
mold
it looks like it's cooking around the
very edge the crepes might be a little
thick but one's a thick crepe
it is a bit rubbery and weird but
cooking okay
I'm gonna taste it I'm gonna try to make
it a little thinner
oh well that's going since technically a
hand mixer is an appliance which I
cannot use I'm hand whipping cream which
it's not my favorite activity look at
the brown it's happening oh yeah got one
done this is so weird that it's actually
making the coffeemaker seem like I'm
normal and easy I can't believe I'm
saying that I rather cook with the
coffee maker we got very reliant on our
appliances the tools and it's good to be
like you know we can make great food
wins really okay I'm going to add a
little sugar look at that I mean this
whipped cream looks really pretty oh no
oh no it's soul okay put this all over
here
[Music]
okay it's sugar finally maybe rinse it's
not just okay I've been making crepes
for two hours now but I think I can
actually start building it they're a
little lopsided so getting the cream
even is gonna be a journey you know I'm
really happy that the crepes actually
worked I was really skeptical when I
first did that parchment paper thing
which was a mistake this is the cutest
thing I've ever seen
next up are the shallots I'm just gonna
keep it on linen that feels like the
best move since I can't use real pots or
pans I'm gonna try to fashion one out of
tin foil it's like a little shallot but
I just want a burner not asking for much
just just a regular partner so usually
when I would make this I would actually
broil the onions but let's see how this
goes
[Music]
the sound is good while those are doing
the thing I can get the rest ready it's
really easy sour cream mayonnaise a
little time for some extra flavor adding
the lemon here for some acidity to lemon
zest
so the shallots are starting to become a
little aromatic they're getting some
browning which looks really great but I
don't think they're gonna get deeply
caramelized and I think for this just a
little golden brown if I can get that
that'll be fine I mean I think this is
the problem with cooking rhythm iron you
can't get really really high heat and
you're so limited by like linen cotton
wolf my dough for the flatbread is more
than ready
so my deal with the flatbread is that I
can make it really thin and then it'll
have a better chance of cooking through
and crispy enough okay this is very thin
so I'll just put it on if this works
this is the coolest thing please work
I'm gonna roll out a few more I really I
don't know I mean the coffee maker was
really hard but since then I've just
been like dreaming if all these other
things I could make and this feels like
the new frontier it's starting to bubble
do you see it
[Music]
okay it's the tiniest tiniest Fleck of
browning I just need like a few brown
spots and then I can flip it there are
brown spots thank you
I'm just gonna put the dip into the bowl
I'm gonna add a few tribes on chopped
just for a bit of extra color put the
flatbread next to it and we're done I'm
gonna move on to the couscous I think
I'm gonna use a measuring cup and heat
the water on top of the iron so usually
when you make couscous well always when
you make couscous if you want to bring
the water to a boil I don't think that's
quite going to happen here but I think I
can get the water to be pretty warm I'm
gonna add some peas to the couscous just
to give it some more body it's honestly
heating up really fast makes me think it
won't come to a full boil but that it
could get significantly hot so I'm gonna
let it go for a few minutes just chop
some scallions and parsley which can be
mixed with the couscous I just added a
little salt pepper and olive oil just to
give it a little more flavor as it cooks
okay I think this is ready I'm gonna do
it hopefully in five minutes this is
will help that's it
fingers crossed I feel like my
confidence level is a solid six right
now
just gonna fluff this couscous a little
and absorb the water not quite cooked
through I think I need to add more water
to it hope this isn't a mistake hot
they're super thin so hopefully this is
going to help my cups see if this works
I wonder if it's gonna get like that
kind of nice browned outside or if it's
just gonna look kind of gray okay
something's happening
so this little bit of brown kind of
slowly but surely I think maybe I just
need to let it
[Music]
okay just gonna go back let's take
another peek
I mean it's cooked it's browned the
backsides a little gray can touch that
up but this I it looks pretty good let's
see this Chris Koos
[Music]
it's cooked it's cooked oh my God thank
God
so I'm gonna add the couscous back to
the scallions parsley okay this little
chop is perfect until next and then good
to go
I'm gonna wrap it up plate everything
I've texted one of my friends Nikki and
she's gonna come up and try this but she
doesn't know that I've made it
completely with an iron why are you so
nervous I don't know why I'm here
did you like make it in a vacuum cleaner
or something is this the appliance show
this is your first course there's a
flatbread and a shoutout dip yeah
delicious your second course is couscous
with peas and lamb chops Wow
lamb chops it's a little fried but let's
do this this put on this thing to move
delicious so you need hard on and your
third course isn't she's beautiful this
is only for me yeah it's only for you go
crazy but my case she's dead she is
dense
dallisa okay so you're right this is the
appliance chef do you want to guess
there's something weird it's an iron you
ironed all of this you just well doc LEM
intimidates me even when I have a whole
kitchen but you did it with just an iron
I'm gonna take this sure thank you so
much that took six hours a lot of trial
and error and if he batches of whipped
cream but I did it it was really cool
and weird and I am excited and kind of
fear what's next stay tuned
[Music]
oh good help me
hey I'm Alexis senior food specialist
here at tasty my friends have challenged
me to cook with a coffee maker I did
that a clothing iron I did that too but
let's see what my producer has in store
at this time oh boy
you have yourself a microwave however
you cannot do any research that seems
fair I feel like I probably need to
elevate it a bit more than a mug cake
good luck my friend thank you feel like
this is too easy like I'm being tricked
microwaves are a really common kitchen
appliance that people use to cook with
every day I know I could make a meal on
microwaves but I really want to
challenge myself to make something
really unexpected do I feel good maybe
for the first course I'm going to make
beet dyed deviled eggs as I was going to
get eggs someone was like eggs are going
to explode in the microwave so I'm going
to put the beets in this dish and pour a
little water in it so like kind of
steams to cook it maybe five minutes
three minutes
I'll start start start slow oh there's a
potato function and a beet is kind of
similar to potato wait wait I mean this
is great that it has the potato function
take some of the guesswork out but it
takes 12 minutes it's gonna be a long
day I felt antsy I feel like excited to
see if this works I'm patient let's say
oh we're good so I'm just gonna boil the
vinegar and water and salt that I'm
gonna have the beet what am i doing okay
well if I'm the expressed time which is
30 seconds so maybe I'm gonna be doing
everything in 30-second intervals so
because the beet is tender now I can
actually just peel the skin right off oh
my god this is gonna be crazy so if I
was doing this at home I would do it in
the oven roast it doesn't really matter
what size they're cut into it's just for
dyeing the pickling liquid the pickling
liquid looks really beautiful colors
really intense this beautiful magenta
dude this one I'm so bad at this yeah
what am I doing wrong like I just want
it to go wait what did you just do but
wait but why would I do that didn't work
okay so if you were gonna hard boil an
egg but in a microwave seven minutes
that feels aggressive I'm gonna go with
six minutes we can do it again
moment of truth cool it down just a hair
I feel so nervous I'm doing a really bad
job peeling is it so hot the white feels
very very conductive I honestly hadn't
considered if it was overcooked
I don't really good egg I'm just gonna
cool these down so I can actually peel
them the longer you let the egg sit in
the pickling liquid the more pink it'll
get I've been really nice for about 25
minutes now but I'm on my last one I'm
gonna move on to the lemon bars this is
where my confidence starts to wane gonna
melt some butter or if the crust so I've
got some flour powdered sugar pinch of
salt I'm going for a faux shortbread
crust per usual I'm just wondering if a
crust is actually going to cook in a
microwave this isn't like an oven I'm
not being able to really bake it so I
think the key for this is gonna go
slowly like doing in increments and
checking just so nothing gets really
like fried gonna press this down it's
not the finest crust over for me so a
bottom layer pizza probably to reheat
pizza maybe I'll just do two minutes and
see what happens it's kind of cooking
baking I think I'll do two more minutes
and see what happens I really want to
make sure that the flour is no longer
for all if we can get a firm crust
that'd be great
so I have these amazing lemons they're
our Meyer lemons so this is what I'm
gonna use to make my curd and I'm gonna
try to make candied lemon peel with
these like beautiful smooth lemons
oh no it's burnt
the good news is that there is some
color on the crust bad news is that I
burnt this so let me give it a taste
[Music]
don't love the texture I'm just gonna do
it again for less time and see what
happens
it smells really bad in here I'm gonna
multitask and at least get the lemon
peels and some hot water the thing is I
can't look up any of the stuff so all
the timing and the voltage is just what
I think is right and I don't know what's
right so two candy lemons first add the
peels to boil in water to remove the
bitterness butter is good at this back
in research would have been really nice
I'm just gonna say that I'm also gonna
fork prick the some of the air can get
out I think that might have to I'll do
two minutes two minutes and then like
one minute and see what happens and then
I'm gonna make a simple syrup with sugar
and water this feels a little chaotic
right now no it's getting like a dark
spot in the middle is maybe this is fine
I mean this is like a pale pale pale
pale pale crusty
put you over here there's a merica Meyer
lemons have a more sweet subtle flavor
than traditional lemons they're amazing
Oh sugar and water are dissolved at the
peels in and usually you would simmer
this over really low heat but again I
can't do that so I'm just gonna let it
hang out so we've got the eggs sugar a
pinch of salt and I'm gonna add a pinch
of cornstarch and then lemon juice so
far this is like you would make regular
cooked I'm gonna try microwaving it in
one minute intervals this doesn't work
we'll just do it again it feels like
I've like buried my nose inside of a
burn popcorn bag it's hard to imagine
that this is going to thicken
that's so usually you'd be simmer in it
but it actually looks like pretty thick
and syrupy it smells really good
whoa so one thing is going well we're
gonna have just candied lemon peel for
dessert oh it does the kitchen oh my god
kind of chunky but I'm gonna taste it I
think I'll put it through the sieve to
get any chunks out I wonder if this is
enough now I guess I'm microwave it
again so if I was doing this at home I
would put it in the oven for a few
minutes just to help it set maybe
Express I'm going back to express that
feels right 30 seconds I'm going to
slice up my little candied lemon peel
and toss it with some sugar and let it
dry I think I'm just gonna chill it and
hope for the best
we're finally at the entree I'm going to
make tomato chips creamy polenta and
halibut and this idea to not roast
garlic but kind of got that a similar
thing I'm going to lop the top off Oh
oh well salt so I would usually just
roast this really low and slow for a
while but let's see what happens if we
do potato IO sawdust idea to make tomato
chips and actually do a little salt the
salts just gonna draw some more moisture
out of them just because I want them to
be as dry as possible when I do put them
in the microwave I'm gonna try to make
the polenta I'm gonna use milk you could
use chicken stock you could do water
maybe the milk is bad idea in this case
though adding some salt
I need like something is fishy here
something's wrong
[Music]
had to intervene sorry
smoking oh it's like on fire I don't
want to say this is a disaster quite yet
but this is really not going very well
well garlic was best which changes some
things so I'm gonna move on to the
polenta and see if this works you know
maybe it was potato
maybe potato was too intense it's so hot
in here it's like at least eighty
degrees and it smells like burnt popcorn
it this is going badly how do I go of
this not good
my confidence level right now is
honestly at a like a three at least I
have can't do nothing for you voila the
thing is I can't let my confidence level
dip too far because then I'm gonna start
messing up it's not over yet oh my god
I honestly like I this is a disaster
what is happening I mean maybe it's fine
no no this is unraveling have you taken
me down in three episodes so I'm gonna
put one fillet I put some tarragon
sometime that's capers would you like to
ask my confidence level it's about it to
sinking right down remember when I was
like I'm gonna inspire people to cook in
their dorm rooms why
better see how this goes I am so nervous
like what if I just don't do it that's
right
so can just let these icky Oh
speaking of all the smells I'm now the
person who puts fish in the microwave
yeah I got cocky I knew it was a trick
I knew it was too good to be true it
feels like tiny bit overdone to me I can
put something on the plate I'm gonna
cook off some more fish for real this
time I feel like it should save one just
in case I think my fish is done let's
just see what happens when we put
tomatoes on microwave
look at those eggs this is really at the
moment of truth oh they're beautiful
the eggs feel a little hard not gonna
lie
the magenta here is like even more
intense than some of the ones I've made
in the past but I really like it
this is gonna be really simple
mayonnaise a mustard called it it's not
great it's not right maybe they will be
distracted by how pretty there is or not
the most eggs my friends
they're so cute oh my god I'm gonna
chill these in the fridge and top them
with chives and bacon a tent I guess I
should see the lemon bars huh the curd
looks good it's not really a pretty even
layer here but you guys this is not good
I don't know if we could really call
this a lemon bar I'm stressing
efficiency it's fun if I can just get
one nice square I'll be thrilled there's
a square I mean look it's not if I can
just plate things really beautifully
maybe it'll distract them no this is not
a thing no one wants to eat this a soggy
tomato
anyway it's fine someone's just gonna
get fish what is the plan
Bacon's last thing words of wisdom nope
good
is there a bacon function bacon in the
microwave what I do it's thing I'm just
worried of whoever tastes this is gonna
be like oh you're a terrible cook
[Music]
guys good rubbery is kind of like the
theme of today honestly this is as good
as it's gonna get right now do I get to
know who's gonna try this Oh God
well this is my new boss Oh
I've prepared a three-course meal I'm so
excited I'm so excited for you to the
first course our beep died deviled eggs
with chives and bacon thank you so much
I wasn't trying to eat this elegantly I
think there's no way that's weird Alyssa
all right the Bacon's really crispy from
the egg whites are the Chinese bit
rubbery on if the other than that I
think it's pretty awesome okay course to
wit I'm a minimalist thing it's a
halibut just tell about the plating is
really pretty
[Music]
should I just leave it's not my favorite
fish dish sure
fine fine feels like a pageant honor
right for your third course you have a
lemon bar with some candied lemon peel
on top to learn that can be your own I
did in a great way coz the curd is super
smooth the first and the third were
really good I really don't know what
crazies you had to do to get to this
place but not bad well do you want to
know what what they put me up laid out
you got to turn around did you cook it
in this microwave all three courses done
in a microwave how did you get the crust
no crispy the first one burned which is
why in the room smells like this I was
concerned about the burning whew smell
when I came in but I'm super impressed
that you did that in the microwave I was
just doing like a stove oh I'm gonna
finish it well over there
Thanks oh that was by far the hardest
thing I've ever had to do here I hate
microwaves it turns out I never want to
cook with one again but I also feel like
maybe I have redemption in my future if
I can research no hopefully next time
will be easier better honestly give me a
coffee maker again
[Music]